foreign
let's go to Rudy in Miami Florida Rudy
how can we help
hey how are you it's an honor today
thank you for the time you bet thanks
for calling what's up nope no problem
okay so to get to the meat and potatoes
of it so a long story short
um I started a business with my ex 12
years ago
um very unique business
um where we manufacture bicycles
um it was great for many many years but
obviously like a typical Story of the
Year
um we broke up a few years back
um so you know for a few years we've
been trying to run the business kind of
like you know Co you know you know
however you want to call it but um but
in the last couple years it's kind of
been like uh a head button very very you
know dramatic type of uh you know
situation you know to the point where
you know it influences employees and
just just in a very toxic environment
um and I've been you know kind of lay
down all the Frameworks of potentially
you know buy her out and see what we can
do but you know currently you know I'm
in a situation where I don't have the
funding that I can buy her out on and
she's actually the strong your partner
of us too so she actually uh you know
she she took a little of the bearing of
the of the credit you know just a little
more debt than I did so she's a little
more reluctant to walk away and really
leave anything on the table
um you know Loose Ends so are you guys
50 50. yes we're 50 50. and that's and
that's not just a handshake that's
that's written down and we've got some
bylaws and we've got all that written
out
oh yeah all written out okay um you know
as interested as you can get she's
actually very very you know I guess you
could say old-fashioned with that so
like everything is overly papered and
all so what's the what's the heart of
your question
the heart of my question is so I want to
continue the business I actually started
the we started together technically 12
years ago but she didn't really start
coming in full time for like a year and
a half later so it really is my baby at
heart but I'm trying to figure out like
how do I get like I'm at the point where
I'm I've invested hundreds of thousand
dollars into this I'm at the point for
my own health sanity you know I study
Finance in schools a random thing I got
into that it's almost worth just signing
over the paperwork and saying have it
all like it's not worth my health and
everything because that's your
relationship you know my new
relationship is amazing but it's
starting to affect it a little bit I you
know and it's just like
I don't know I feel like the energy if I
sign it off yeah and she doesn't want to
sell the business right like you guys
don't want to just get out both of you
she always says she does but she's kind
of like she comes from a lot of money
will she buy you out will she buy you
out
that's what I've been trying to do and
that's what I've been trying to get her
to do but she just keeps throwing it at
me like this is you know I'm I'm not I
have no interest in this so I'm not
going to get any further yep so you
can't control her Rudy so for you and
your sanity I mean you could chalk it up
to what we call stupid text around here
I'd walk I think you answered the
question yourself you just kind of laid
it out hurt it's gonna hurt but it may
be worse in the long run Rudy I'm sorry
yeah I would follow your heart on this
this is why y'all don't go into business
when you're not married
man oh boy fruity sorry yeah you gotta
walk man
this is the Ramsey Show